It looks like a kid dam toddler. Yes
, there is no narrow floor or second floor.
How to get back to the original I'll find out soon.
But good
[music]
goo
with ana, it's
Darwin's Rio 6, but
it's not a kid. It's fun even if the body gets smaller, isn't it?
What's new?
[Music]
Just in the village  I'm glad I had a child-sized clothes
When I was a kid, I'm a kid.
I'm not a kid, but
it's good for the overflowing display of a child of the age while listening.
This is a kid's
lunch
I tried to make it fancy just for Azusa-sama.
I'm looking for a way to withdraw and return to
ana Azusa-sama
, can
I throw it on ours even though I'm a requester?
It's too thick, it's a
little puffy, it's too cute, it's just a light
, it's sly. Pratorte is gently stroking it, isn't it?
The one on the right is
waiting for me.